هشام زقوط وانت تحدثنا من مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى نرى خلفك اعداد كبيره تجتمع لربما
لاداء صلاه الجنازه على عدد كبير ايضا من
الشهداء الذين نشاهد جثامينهم مسجاه على
الارض هل هؤلاء من ضحايا قصف امس
المكثف بالفعل خلال 24 ساعه في المنطقه
الوسطى هناك 70 شهيد من جراء عمليات
الاستهداف المركزه والقصف المكثف على مخيم
البريج ومخيم المغاز وايضا الاستهداف في
دير البلح بغارات لمنازل مدنيه فلسطينيه
وكان هناك اكثر من 15 شهيدا في اي دير
البلح وسط القطاع هنا ستتم عمليه صلاه
الجنازه على هؤلاء الشهداء واغلبهم من
عائله مطر في دير البلح حيث استهدف الجيش
الاسرائيلي منزلهم وسواه بالارض وكان هناك
عشرات من الشهداء اكثر من 15 شهيده من
عائله مطر لوحدها فيما هناك ايضا شهداء من
المنازل المجاوره لهذا المنزل بالتاكيد
دمار كبير في كل منزل يستهدفه الجيش
الاسرائيلي في دير البلح او في غيرها من
تلك المناطق لكن دير البلح بات القصف فيها
مركز من الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
لاسما وان عندما نتحدث عن دير البلح نحن
نتحدث عن المكان او المنطقه التي قال
الجيش الاسرائيلي لسكان المنطقه الوسطى ان
توجهوا الى دير البلح وبالتالي بعد ذلك
يقصف بالطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه ويسوي
هذه المنازل بالارض يتم احضار هؤلاء
الشهداء وهم ظلوا طوال هذه الفتره منذ امس
وحتى اليوم مسجون على الارض لانه لا يتوفر
مكان في ثلاجات الموتى واصلا ثلاجات
الموتى باتت لا تعمل بسبب نقص الوقود
وبالتالي لا لا تستطيع المستشفى تشغيل هذه
الثلاجات وبالتالي عمليه اصلا
اي دفن هؤلاء الجثامين اصلا تواجه صعوبه
جسيمه لا سما ونحن نتحدث عن مخيم المغازي
مخيم البريج والمقابر الموجوده فيها هي هي
لا لا تستط لا يستطيع السكان الوصول اليها
وايضا دير البلح المقبره المتواجده فيها
هي ممتلئه للغايه ايضا مخيم النصيرات
المقبره الموجوده فيه ممتلئه للغايه
وبالتالي هناك صعوبه الان في عمليه دفن
هؤلاء ايضا هناك صعوبه في عمليه ايصال
هؤلاء الى المقابر لا سما و في ظل نقص
الوقود فهذه المستشفيات لم تعود قادره على
ايصال الجثامين بهذه الاعداد الكبيره الى
المقابر في ظل هذا النقص الحد في الوقود
والنقص الحد في الوقود هو مستمر ومتواصل
منذ بدايه هذه الحرب الاسرائيليه
والمستشفيات تنادي بامداد بكميات وفيره من
الوقود ل من اجل الاستمرار في العمل
الاستمرار في تقديم الخدمات للسكان في ظل
هذا العبء الكبير الذي تواجهه هذه
المستشفيات وهي التي باتت وتحولت الى
مراكز للايواء وايضا مراكز لتقديم الرعايه
الصحيه والاسعافات الاوليه لهؤلاء السكان
في ظل هذا النقص الحاد في الوقود فهي
بالكات تستطيع تقديم
القليل من الرعايه الصحيه وبعض من اقسام
هذه المستشفيات باتت لا تعمل كثات الموتى
بسبب عمليات التوفير في الوقود وفي عمليات
التشغيل بالتالي هو ازمه ك وازمه وراء
ازمه و في تفاصيل كل هذه الازمات هو هي
الحرب الاسرائيليه المستمره على قطاع غزه
وكما نستمع هناك اصوات انفجارات في كل
لحظه وفي كل حين من قبل المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه التي تكثف من قصفها ل المناطق
الشرقيه لقطاع غزه والمناطق الشرقيه
للمنطقه الوسطى بالتحديد مع كل صباح ربما
تنخفض حده الغارات الاسرائيليه من الجو
ولكنها تتكثف من المدفعيه الاسرائيليه ومن
الزوارق الحربيه الاسرائيليه على شواطئ
مدينه بئر البلح وايضا الزوايده ومخيم
النصيرات وشاهدنا اطلاق نار كثيف في تلك
المناطق من قبل هذه الزوارق بينما ايضا
تكثف المدفعيه الاسرائيليه من قصفها لمخيم
البريج ومخيم المغازي ومخيم البريج ما زال
محاصرا بفعل استمرار القصف الاسرائيلي
السيارات الاسعاف وسيارات الدفاع المدني
لا تستطيع الوصول الى هذا المخيم وبالتالي
انتشال الجثامين وايضا اجلاء الجرحى ومن
يصاب في تلك المنطقه هو يبقى ينزف حتى
الموت ولا تستطيع سيارات الاسعاف والطواقم
الطبيه تقديم اي اسعافات اوليه له بسبب
منع الجيش الاسرائيلي وصول وصولهم الى تلك
المناطق ايضا منطقه مهمه تشهد اشتباكات
وايضا تشهد عمليات قصف مكثفه هي في
خانيونس ربما المناطق الشرقيه لخاني وس
تتعرض في كل لحظه وفي كل حين الى قصف من
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه وما زالت الاشتباكات
فيها مستمره لكن منطقه وسط خانيونس تشهد
قصفا عنيفا في هذه اللحظات من قبل
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه وايضا شهدت خانيونس
والمنطقه الوسطى والشرقيه احزمه ناريه
نفذتها الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه في
هذا في في تلك المناطق لكن حتى عمليات
التمشيط حتى الان غير ممكنه بسبب استمرار
القصف الاسرائيلي بسبب وجود مسي
في السماء تطلق النار على كل من يتحرك في
المناطق التي يسيطر عليها الجيش
الاسرائيلي او يسعى لمنع وصول المواطنين
اليها في منطقه رفح ايضا المناطق الشرقيه
تشهد منذ يومين على الاقل قصفا عنيفا من
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه وهذا القصف متواصل
ما بين فينه واخرى في مدينه غزه وشمال
القطاع ربما الاحوال باتت مختلفه لا سما
وان المناطق الشرقيه حي التفاح وحي الدرج
هي التي تشهد القصف العنيف بينما المناطق
الاخرى تشهد اطلاق
من قبل المسيرات في ظل انسحاب الجيش
الاسرائيلي واعاده تمركزه وتموضع في مناطق
بعيده عن المناطق التي كان يتواجد فيها في
مخيم الشاطئ وحي الشيخ رضوان ومنطقه
المقوس شكرا جزيلا لك من مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى في دير البلح مراسل الجزيره هشام
زقوت